gentlemen we're live okay we are
officially live uh folks if you're
tuning in
uh you may want to share this podcast
and here's why because the first live
glimpse the world's going to see
uh sammy and michael being on will be on
this podcast momentarily
they are getting ready to get in the
room the moment we're in there we're
going to let them in we'll go live and
you'll hear from them
uh we've had a lot of anticipation for
this project obviously a lot of you have
been asking about this
uh it started off with a a a smaller
project originally mario you remember
when this whole conversation happened
when uh a few years ago shout out to
bill mcintyre she made the first
introduction to michael that's right and
he said you got to do this interview and
then we had a year and a half and then
the first time we went to michael's
house right after jordan belfort's house
if you remember that it was on the
christmas time oh my god it was december
23rd i want to say
and we went to michael's house we sat
down in his living room newport when we
did the first interview no shoes we had
no idea that no shoe was a big deal a
lot of people did not like that but you
know the fact that i had my shoes on he
did not anyways we did that interview we
left we had no idea what's going to
happen we've never done a mob interview
before obviously there's been a lot of
interest in the movie godfather
goodfellas you know uh donnie
call following these movies right so
people always want to know what this
life was like but that was insight to
know how michael was making 8 10 a week
the kind of businesses he was doing
uh in new york and then we left the
interview went live
next thing you know it's on the cover of
a homepage of worldstar and everybody
picked it up it got a million views two
million views three million views ten
million views then sammy we had a
meeting with sammy we had a conversation
with a multiple you remember the first
time we met with sammy it was an
interesting very very good yes he's a
very animated individual yes i remember
the first time you met him
and then we did sammy's interview same
story both at things that 12 13 million
views they both have hundreds of million
views right now both successful youtube
channels michael's running i think he's
had a million sami's about to be at a
million both of them doing very good for
themselves uh with their content the
world wants to know you know how that
life was like so
having said that um
this will be the first time they'll be
live
and uh uh we have some big announcements
with mafia states of america that you
guys been anticipating it's 10 episodes
the amount of time mario how many people
have been working on this project all
this time dozen people since we launched
the project uh
how many people were on this set almost
50 people almost 50 people working on
the set half a million dollar budget
rudy giuliani chas parliamentary
narrating uh written and directed by
gerard michaels who is on a flight right
now to jersey or else it'd be here with
us
uh and then we have uh michael and sammy
so having said that i think if we're
ready
uh david you give us the green light if
you have him in the waiting room we're
ready to go if you're ready so
we're gonna wait on him to give us the
green light and we'll get into it and i
think the most rare thing about this
project is the fact that there has never
been a sit-down of this magnitude in the
history of mafia you go on youtube right
now you type in greatest sit-downs of
all time you're not going to see
this level of quality this level of
conversation this kind of a story line
and this is not a scripted thing this is
a real conversation a real life sit down
with two of the most interesting
individuals we have monsters we have
them on right now so michael sammy if
you want to unmute yourself how are you
guys
can you hear us
okay patrick
fantastic i'm good too
excellent sammy michael can you guys
hear us
i can hear you
i can hear you too okay wonderful well
first of all thank you guys for making
the time
uh uh to be on uh with us i know the
audience has been anticipating this for
a while
uh uh obviously uh uh when we had that
sit down together we were together for
three days i think nearly 30 hours of
footage which has now come to a
completion of 10 episodes
uh of which there's behind the scenes
there's a lot of different things that
the audience will be seeing but you know
i kind of want to ask you guys a couple
open-ended questions how are you doing
right now with
in regards to this project being
launched how are you guys doing to
yourself maybe michael if you can uh
tell us
on your end of your level of enthusiasm
with this mafia states of america
project i'm doing great patrick i just
want to get it underway a lot of people
are asking about it
you know a lot of different comments and
it's time we get it out there you know
i'm very enthused to see it happen
sammy how about yourself
i guess yes uh i'm
waiting for it to come out i've been
waiting a while
it's a little awkward time right now but
i'm waiting for it to come out as well
well i remember when we had you on the
podcast you made it very clear when i
said it may come out this year it may
come out next year you had a very
strategic way of making sure it came out
this year which is
uh uh coming out in 2021 instead of next
year
and we're pretty excited about launching
it but uh
michael uh uh sammy uh for yourself
the market you know it seems so many
people are anticipating this
conversation between the two of you uh
specifically since we had so many
different discussions from the life on
your end uh what where are you at right
now yourselves
uh knowing at this phase of the season
when this is being launched meeting has
there been
any conversations between the two of you
about this project yourself so sami what
are you thinking right now what's on
your mind
well we did have conversations about it
and i thought we were on the same page
as far as trying to uh put this back
together
and solving our problems
i'm not sure if this did solve our
problems
uh michael put out a video just not too
low and i didn't like this [ __ ] video
and i think we had some words
so uh but we still did this i don't want
to interfere with the project i don't
want to destroy it or hurt it in any way
and uh
but um
i'm looking forward to it i watched uh
not all of the episodes but some of them
looks like they're pretty well done
and um there's some issues i have with
some of the things and some of the
conversations that me and michael have i
think we'll straighten it out
after this or before it i i don't really
care when but uh
so that's my opinion of it right now
got it so
you know
michael sammy uh maybe uh it's good for
the audience to hear from your and when
you first flew in and we came to the
property and we had that one meeting
together in the room it was myself the
two of you
i want to say
kurt was there i think richie was a few
people were involved in that meeting
that we had in that room uh next door
what was your expectation going in and
then at the same time what was your uh
uh you know outcome at the end when you
left was it what you expected it to be
when you left what was your thoughts
when you went in and when you left
michael yourself
yeah i didn't know what to expect look
sammy and i have uh you know two
different uh
perceptions of this life both before and
after
and i knew that that was going to be
some controversy between us and
obviously it was patrick you were there
you know i think we got heated at times
because we do strongly disagree
um but you know all in all
look we're two maid guys and at the end
of the day i think we knew how to
conduct it ourselves even though things
got heated at times you know
it's kind of like a blast back to the
past and you kind of remember the way
things are supposed to go and i think in
the end they went that way you know how
we feel about each other right now i
don't know look sammy said something he
said i didn't like
and maybe i said some things that he
didn't like and as a result there's
still some tension between us but
that's just the way it goes you know
it's uh you know how it how it
ultimately ends up is really you know
depends on the two of us and we'll see
what happens
yeah well michael
it's not that you know the way it ended
i thought it ended good i think it went
well between us
and uh just recently you put out an
inter uh a video
that i'm completely disturbed with we
had language back and forth with each
other i think we know let's not [ __ ]
so right now i feel betrayed by you
by what you put out
what we did on this
program
was a beautiful thing you're right it
was goes in austria in full bloom again
it made me feel good about sitting with
you it maybe changed my opinion of you
and i think it went very well
that we did have some heated
times
but end result it went like goes in
austria it's supposed to go
but what you did after that that video
really disturbed the [ __ ] out of me up
until right now i didn't even want to
sit down on this video to tell you the
truth
but i'm in this deep i went in this far
and i'm not the type of guy who's going
to walk away and leave everybody
dangling
so
that's that's the way i feel from that
video but the the the
mafia states of america that situation
and what patrick did and what you did
yes we do have tremendous differences of
opinion
along as it goes on
as far as destroying families and all of
that stuff
you know it did to some people but not
to other people
and when we talk about people who
cooperated
which you did as well
with navi walters you want to really get
into that right now
but
you know to sit there and say you know
this is horrible what these people did
and they caught a break
and uh
all of this stuff
belittling them and putting them down
for another program that's going to come
out with john gotti jr
i
blew me away
and then the second thing you
you prayed for me
that's another thing that bloom really
blew me away because i'm not a fool
i'm a street thug i'm just as smart as
you
maybe you underestimate my education
compared to your education but i know
when i'm being [ __ ]
okey-doke or try to make me soft uh get
take it easy because of the video it's
not supposed to bother me no more
but it does and it made it that was like
icing on the cake to me
so it made me real angry okay let me let
me tell you this let me make this very
clear
i didn't betray you i had no intent to
betray you i still don't even understand
what you're so upset about but whatever
you you got upset and what i did
afterwards to not make you upset for
whatever reason you had i took that
little 10 second spot out of the video
that's number one number two when it
comes to the witness protection program
i'm sorry sammy i have my thoughts on it
i've been to trial five times i saw my
father go to trial four times i seen
guys lie and manipulate that program to
stay out of prison i'm not accusing you
or anybody else i'm accusing the people
that i witnessed that i saw it happen
and i'll take that to my grave a lot of
guys use the program to manipulate the
government it's easy to do they come up
with [ __ ] stories to put somebody in
jail that has a bigger name than them
and that happens all the time and you're
smart enough on the street to know that
that's the truth and that's what i said
as far as john gotti with his wits like
mafia all i said was he's coming out
with a show it's called whitsec mafia
that's it you didn't just say that
yes i did no you didn't
let me
let me finish let me respond to you guys
the video is up there anybody can see it
the only part that was edited was the 10
seconds that i had about you and all i
said was sammy was in the program i
didn't say anything else about it so i
didn't betray you nor that i didn't let
all right i got your point let me
explain now what you did you got to let
me finish i let you finish it
finished what are you gonna do
so again yeah you know going back to
what you said i thought things went kind
of well we had our differences we still
have our differences about it maybe we
straightened it out obviously maybe we
didn't you still have something in your
mind as far as a prayer that i sent to
you let me explain that we were in
church my wife sat next to me okay the
pastor said you know uh pray for
somebody that you think needs prayer
today that needs to come to the lord my
wife turned to me and said let's pray
for sammy and so we prayed for you and i
sent you that had nothing to do with
that video because sammy contrary to
what you believe i don't need to soften
you up for anything that was just
ridiculous what you said it made no
sense whatsoever all right
if you don't you've done it you're gonna
talk for [ __ ] three hours yeah one
second if you don't accept my faith
that's up to you i've heard that for 20
years and it doesn't except nothing
you're saying i only i don't accept
nothing you say the problem is with some
of the things i'll start what you just
said what your father said
you said to me on on the thing with when
you cooperated against nabi walters that
your father and
karma persico agreed with it
no i didn't say that hold no don't put
words in my mouth what i said was very
very simple and the truth and this is a
matter of record so everybody can be
asked about this whole norby walters
things it's a matter of record what i
said was i knew exactly what i was doing
at the end of the day norbie walters
wasn't going to do one minute in jail
and he never did and neither did anybody
else i talked to the government all
right all right you made your point
nobody did don't go into attention no no
no no no no i made a point
you've accused me of this i'll accuse
your flag
walters i've got a lot of information
with that and a lot of friends involved
well i'm going to put it out i'm going
to tell you right now right to your
[ __ ] face i'm going to tell you
walters you testified against him he
went he got convicted
nobody
didn't do what he said to me nobody has
nothing to do with you how much time he
did a judge in the case made a mistake
why do you feel a need to cover for
yourself
okay by saying what i did why i'm not
covering for myself yes you are no i
never you are you want to make a big
deal out
you don't have a leg to stand on when it
comes to that if you shut your
[Music]
what i said very simply and i said it a
thousand times and i'll say it again
nobody went to jail because of anything
i ever said to the government bottom
line period
you made that point if you know it made
that point bring it
when i bring it up why would you put my
[ __ ] name in with john dotty jr and
that hucking tape about people who
cooperated watch the damn thing i did
watch the [ __ ] thing three times i
watched
you put my name in it well you know what
if i i said to you i was man enough to
say to you if i put your name in it and
it offended you i apologize to you you
can't accept it because there was no
intent
wrong on that whatsoever may i may i
make may i make one question so
uh uh michael uh you know you've uh
addressed your side of it sammy what's
the what's your biggest challenge with
that what was it that upsets you the
most about what was said i mean he
mentioned the name
you know first of all
he likes to work with innuendos
the innuendo is that people who get
convicted
should never be released because they
cooperated that's the first [ __ ]
innuendo then he says if the proof is in
the pudding that
when they get released they recommit now
i cooperated one
two i did recommit
so when you put me with those group of
guys even though he only talked about me
for a second or two or ten seconds
and saying sammy he put me in that group
so the innuendo i got 30 40 50 people
who were friends of mine who called me
or texted me or sent messages why are
you letting this [ __ ] bum
talk about you like that
when he cooperates why are you letting
me what are you doing what are you going
to do what do they mean what why are you
letting because i don't talk i don't
talk the facts about you that's why
you want if you want to talk about facts
we could let out the facts i mean if you
were sitting in person i would show you
why you can't but if you want to let me
stop yes
don't tell me stop no i'll tell you stop
stop
okay we don't need to go there we're not
going to go whatever you want it doesn't
matter what's in our
to me where we hands
i don't care where we go
wherever you want to go we go
if you want to put out things like that
and make an innuendo that i'm one of
those [ __ ] guys
i'm telling you to your face there was
no innuendo you took it that way i i
don't know what's in your brain or
what's in your head why is it bothering
you that i'm talking about navi walters
and you testified why is that part of
you
it doesn't bother me said it let's talk
about it i'll tell you about it i can
tell you about the case just tell the
truth that's why oh you don't know the
[ __ ] truth i know the truth sammy
you don't have a [ __ ] clue what it is
to tell the truth whether it's
christianity or what it is sammy you're
talking to me stop the baloney okay you
don't want to go there either when we
talk about the truth don't think that
you're the guardian of the truth here
okay one thing i do i don't buckle from
the truth i tell the truth whatever it
is i don't know why sammy so do i i got
nothing to hide no
what are you repositive about it with
god nabi walters why are you bothered
you told the people on
on the program i watched it and i
watched that episode where you said
watch it again
i i will i did
whatever i said there i'm saying right
now okay
you want to know something you want to
stand on nobody walters to make yourself
feel better
no i don't no i don't be walking don't
give a [ __ ] about nobody walters i don't
even know him so what are you bringing
it up for because you testified you said
i never testified i never put anybody
away
no he went away he got convicted it's
not bull it's the truth sammy oh
absolute truth i'll say it again i've
said it a thousand times and you bring
proof different stop talking
video
nobody ever went to jail because of
anything i ever told the government can
you say the same sami no no so don't
give me your i don't try to say the same
so i don't try to cover i don't try to
lie i don't i
did something no i just i'll challenge
you you tell me who i put in prison
nobody's i just told you
you have no [ __ ] ammunition to put
anybody in prison anyway yeah you never
broke a [ __ ] egg
they had no they didn't give a [ __ ]
about you here you go again trying to
tell everybody you know everything you
don't know a damn thing about me my life
or my family stop the balloon i never
did i was on the [ __ ] street who the
[ __ ] knew who you are you were nothing
to me really the father had a name
huh who the hell knew you either then
stop the bologna who the [ __ ] in the mob
says stop the baloney what kind of
statement is that
oh no no now you want now you want to
act like a clown what do you mean or
stop the baloney i'm gonna act like a
crowd stop the [ __ ]
let me tell you something who had more
damn respect on the street than my
father and you got the nerve stop using
your father i don't use my father i made
my own name you stopped using gotti i
made my own name
who the hell knew you until this whole
thing happened with ganny my friend my
friend
came to me for [ __ ] help he was
finished he came to me
sammy you could bs everybody on youtube
you know no no no no no
media's [ __ ] government there's state
there's people in the street who know it
yeah right yeah it's a good story sammy
it's a good story it's all made up on
youtube it's all made up it's a story
for everybody on youtube sam no see here
here's your innuendos when you talk you
say you know everybody who's in the
street has to make their phones wait no
innuendo sammy i'm answering you
straight out
okay quit answering me straight out
about what about whatever you want
anything you want you just said i got
nothing to do with the [ __ ] thing
with girl john dodd who the [ __ ] needed
john gotti john gotti actually destroyed
my [ __ ] life in a lot of other
people's lives i needed him like i
needed a [ __ ] 38 and a half john
gotti's a good scapegoat for everybody i
know because he's not a scapegoat it's
what he did
please
you can't you can't get away from what
you did in history you can't get away
just like you can't get away you got
your father's name period
yeah let me tell you something sammy
what i did on the street i did you can
keep using that bs what did you do you
said it being that hey what the [ __ ] you
did what'd you do
what did you do i did a lot it's all
over the place what did you do how did
you do it sammy i'm involved in 19. what
did you do free [ __ ] mafia
badge of honor your badge of honor you
killed 19 you put a gun in a [ __ ]
back of 19 guys that's your no i didn't
shoot 19 guys i'm involved in 19 murders
sammy yeah yeah
i'm involved in free mafia
i don't i've made the construction
business with unions what'd you do with
the [ __ ] phony [ __ ] with the gas
taking down performers
phony your phone sammy you're [ __ ] me
you didn't try to take down michael
jackson it didn't work
oh sammy you know what stop you're not
you're you're talking like a clown right
now i just got caught i see the
ammunition you got i got one question
samuel that's it sammy if the audience
is watching
uh uh our outcome was the way you know
our outcome was to
you know a lot of people ask me and they
say so pat what do you think this has
led to with all these conversations i
said number one
uh you know
if you look at the lifestyle on what's
happened you know both michael and sammy
they're no longer part of the life both
of them are on businesses michael runs
successful businesses sammy's
doing very well for himself as well
which means
this was a way out this this worked out
creating content telling stories etc etc
and you've gone to a different life now
your grandparents parents it's a
different phase you're no longer 20s 30s
when you're in the hunt want to go there
that's a completely different life
you're living right now and there there
is a sincere feel of you wanting to make
a transition into the next life but
sammy the question i have is
some of the audience that's listening to
this right now they see the frustration
between the two of you they still don't
know what was
what was so michael made a comment about
your name being there he says sammy
drops your name 11 seconds he cuts it
what part of that reference upset you
though what was that because i don't
think fully the audience knows what
frustrated you with that comment if you
don't mind elaborating that if you're
comfortable with that
when you make [ __ ] statements about
people
about their cooperation
and why they shouldn't get out of prison
and you make statements that the proof
is in the pudding when they get out they
lie to the government
they turn around and they recommit
crimes and he mentions a couple of
people including my name in that group
my name didn't have to be in that group
he could have if that's was his feelings
he's gonna just said that
he didn't have to put my [ __ ] name in
the thing
that's number one
number two
when he he cooperated and did certain
things it was all right for him to
cooperate against nobby walters whether
he went to prison or not he got
convicted under michael's testimony he
got a 395 000 fine he got sentenced to
prison and the case was overturned
because the judge
made a mistake on the case
something that affected the law end of
it not michael or his testimony or
nothing and the case was reversed
he comes out of [ __ ] prison
there was there's interviews people
wanted to talk to me they don't even
want to talk about michael francis or
his father he hates them
so and this guy here was a family friend
of this
family friend they shook them down for
money and then routed on them
and that's supposed to be okay so you
could do that but somebody else who has
a problem in them if they were betrayed
or whatever their story is
you that you're going to be the high
priestess who tells them you're no good
you shouldn't get out when he was able
to get out he had a 10-year sentence
a 10-year sentence that was reduced to
three years of four months
for his [ __ ] testimony you you were
there when we talked about his 15
million dollar fine
he never paid it
he says well i paid ribs and drebs but i
never paid at all
you can walk away from the [ __ ]
government and say i'm not paying it
that don't work that was probably done
because he cooperated whatever his fine
was they probably niched it
whatever they did
i can't prove that i can't say that but
those things don't just disappear
they're there
so without cooperation you ain't getting
these things from the government there's
millions of people who went to prison
you can't get squat
from the government when you're
convicted nothing
whether it's a fine whether it's the
time
reductions you've got to do something to
get reactions
and there's there's tapes there's agents
saying yeah the argument the the new
york prosecutors were arguing with the
chicago prosecutors they wanted him to
cooperate against
carmine persico
he wouldn't do it or whatever that is i
i don't doubt maybe he didn't want to do
it and he didn't
but the chicago people won out they used
him there and he got his favors he
cooperated now
he didn't have murders he don't he never
murdered anybody in his life from what i
understand that's but he'll say i know i
don't have cover for that
so i can't talk about it it's another
innuendo
of making the people whose people think
well he did what he had to do to get
into life and you don't want to talk
about it why don't you just be truthful
and say i never killed anybody
your followers probably a lot of them
who are christians would say that's good
he never killed anybody
but he just can't it can't seem to tell
the truth when it comes to these things
i don't know why
i really don't
so that's why and that's why he had a
lot of guys on the street who he says
they're nobodies
and uh and he knows who they are i don't
want to mention their names because i
don't want to start a [ __ ] revolution
here but they they just badmouth them
all the time until i got into the
picture how could you do anything he
tells me i got into the people into the
picture that i shut them all up
michael ain't a bad guy leave him alone
he lied so he lied that's none of your
business
leave it alone
john gotti jr is not my [ __ ] friend
he's going to do this thing
uh my uh wet sack mafia and he's going
to bed now people now i'm going to give
you and your whole audience and michael
guess who the [ __ ] he's going to hurt
the most he'll come after most it'd
probably be me and he's congratulating
him on his project
and and there's a guy another made guy
riding on everybody and his mother
which is insane
and i don't know why you would talk good
about him
he met with the government he's done a
[ __ ] gazillion [ __ ] things
that it's it's a complete joke
so now when he did that video
and the thing that bothered me the most
was
that him and his wife and kids are in
church and they're praying for me
he had a catastrophe have it
a week or two before
with a young boy it's not his fault
he could pray for him why do you want to
pray for me i'm not sick i'm not dead
i'm not in jail why would you want to
pray for me
so i took that
little prayer you sent me
as
he's trying to soften me up from this
video
he knew i would explode at that video
because we're supposed to at this point
be getting along then you put out this
video you tap him on the back let me get
back to john gotti's doing it him
himself he's sitting in
health magazine health health men's
health magazine
stating
that he is a crime fighter now
he wants to put people in prison
he wants to do stories about people who
should have never got out of prison
how hypocritical is this
and he wants to say oh he's doing a
great job
this is your father who did 50 years
and it's a cooperative but this is a guy
who's who wants to put people in prison
he says it he admits it
publicly
it's in magazines
so i got to sit here and listen to this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
after trying my best to do the right
thing with this show
and have a relationship with him and put
things in the past
a couple of days goes by and there's
this [ __ ] video and i get 40 50
[ __ ] people calling me
i said i don't know why he did it
and i'm sitting there like a jackass
over and over again
well i don't know
i ain't a bad guy he i don't know why he
did it i don't even know what the [ __ ]
to say
to people
and then this
emergency meeting comes up with me and
michael i don't want to hurt the project
i don't want to hurt nothing i didn't
want to be here you know it
but i said i'll i'll be here
and then we exploded just now at each
other i don't know what it does to the
project i hope it don't hurt it i i
don't know what it does and i don't
really care
not it's
can i respond to this please sure go
forward
can i respond to this first of all
first of all i don't know who these 40
or 50 people are at number one number
two
number two
again i didn't say anything positive
about j sammy says i do innuendos he
makes things up i didn't say anything
positive about john gotti i mentioned a
public fact that john gotti is coming
out with something called the whitsect
mafia i told sammy this i never met john
gotti i never spoke to john gotti jr
talking about junior i have no
relationship with him whatsoever i've
never communicated with him other than
one time with his lawyer 10 12 years ago
that was it
that's number one so i don't even know
what he's upset about with that i have
no relationship and i told sammy that
and that's the godzilla you told him you
said he's doing a great job let me
finish i didn't say he's doing a great
job let me finish okay that's number one
when it comes to norby walters sammy
seems to claim to know everything about
everything norby walters here's the
facts with norby walters three times
three times i saved his life once from
corki vestola once from carmine
persiclow and once from my father
because he was using our name never paid
us any money he never got shook down he
used us for 30 years and that's the
reason he was in trouble in the stage
delication okay i saved his life when my
father came home from prison and wanted
to hurt him i can say that now because
my father's gone i think i've said it
before that's number one so when this
situation came up with norbie walters
and i was subpoenaed number one first
they subpoenaed my father and they
subpoenaed my younger brother and what i
told them i said look i'll tell you the
truth about norby okay when i get put on
the stand let my father and brother
alone they did and when i got on the
stand you could look at the testimony
it's public record what it said on the
stand is i don't know who norbi is
shaking down i've been in prison i don't
know i gave him 275 000 to be involved
in this deal i got involved because i
wanted to meet athletes for my gambling
situation that's exactly what i told him
yeah nobody got convicted and you know
what he had 25 people testify against
about the actual facts that happened in
the case so if you want to talk facts
don't just blow it off talk facts get
the damn testimony look at the trial
don't be like written house like
everybody had him convicted until the
evidence comes out in the trial the poor
kid got got you know persecuted for no
reason i said talk facts that's number
one as far as number two what i did on
the street you
have a knowledge of sammy don't claim to
know everything about everybody else's
business what i did with persico or my
father or anybody else who i killed or
didn't kill you have no knowledge of so
trust stop trying to make people think
you know everything about everything
because you don't
all right i don't know let me finish i
did not interrupt you i did not
interrupt you oh my god
that's no more number two i'm telling
you this right now you can knock my
faith like you've been doing in almost
every interview that you keep going back
stop going back to your christianity i'm
responding to you we're talking about
the mafia exclusive
you brought it up you brought
what's the matter you can't have a
response
only you can have a response
no when you bring something up you're
entitled to a response yeah yeah you
said it nine times already oh you said
it again you said it again i said what
you brought it up for me for no reason
when you have somebody die in your house
there's a reason for play for him pray
for him every day he's already in heaven
you don't even stop the [ __ ] [ __ ]
i said to you no you stop your bs take
the text and put it up on the screen if
you want to be a big shot put it up on
the screen exactly what i said let me
ask you a question
let me fight well no i don't i want to
say it one thing at a time you always
want you to go on [ __ ] you don't give
anything i want to say something how did
you get that break
how did they go from 10 years to three
[ __ ] years in prison first of all
three years old excuse me don't lie i
did eight years on the ten eight years
stop with your bs 3.4 i did eight years
it's a matter of record look up the bop
records stop what you did 40 months
stop putting your baloney you did 40
months years 29 months and seven days in
solitary because i wouldn't cooperate so
stop the baloney stop trying to cover
your own self by putting the blame
elsewhere sammy stop i don't do that to
you and you don't need to do that to me
what i did is a matter of public record
the same as you
and i don't care who looks at it
that you went and cooperated against
navi waltz and you want to say you went
there and saved him i just i didn't say
that
no you
do you have any idea what you're talking
about no yeah i know do you you and i
tell you something i see what i'm
talking about you went to testifying
what did you do go to help them did you
hear what i just said i'm not going to
deny it
i was subpoenaed and i told the truth
subpoenaed where were gangsters it's
peter don't mean nothing
you don't go
sammy you tell him i refuse to answer
that let me show you
the [ __ ] stand oh you don't go who
the hell are you what do you mean you
don't go you went how many times i'm
what i'm talking about i cooperated i
never went before sammy i never sat with
the government before
why did you have to
only when i cooperated only when you had
yeah of course why else would you sit
down
sammy yeah let me make so [ __ ] legit
that's a legitimate guy
i got surprised i gotta go
sammy you can paint this any color that
you want here's the facts i testified
into norby walters case go look up your
damn youtubes i said it 20 times okay
and all i ever said and i'll take this
to my grave and you can do all your
[ __ ] research that you want nobody
went to prison because of anything i
ever said i made sure that can you say
the same
are you right i know exactly what i'm
talking about because i lived it not you
you can pretend to live it you can
pretend to know everything but that's
all i told you i think you lost your
[ __ ] mind you
what
we i think we're losing sami's signal do
you want to call sammy on the phone so
we can get him on the audio
michael let me ask you did the
from that from that moment of the video
and your text exchange that you're
saying
uh uh uh you'd be willing to share it
did you guys have a phone call together
or there's not been a phone call or
zoomed together just been tested that's
right as soon as he sent me the text i
said sammy i didn't mean to offend you
i'll take it down i looked at it again
i talked to kurt we had our team take it
off because there was nothing he got his
feelings hurt for that all he had to do
was say to me why did you do that oh
this is sammy you know what if it hurt
you i'm sorry i would have taken it out
which i did immediately
immediately with all this prayer
bullying innuendo i don't know what the
heck he's talking about it's all figment
of his imagination i took it down it was
you know what i'll tell you the truth
i'll tell you honest i am my wife said
you know what michael i can understand
how sammy got offended i said okay i
didn't get it you know what and i'm
sorry i'm not making excuses we just had
a kid die in my house maybe i wasn't
thinking right i don't know
but it certainly wasn't to offend him in
any way and i don't have to soften him
up i don't know what he's talking about
send him something and what happened at
church patrick you will understand this
yeah i don't have to pray for somebody
maybe it's what your wife told you
it's maybe what your wife told you
michael would you [ __ ] just did
is not right no your wife told you jimmy
don't inject again many other people
gotta tell excuse me
was wrong don't inject it again sammy my
wife told me days afterwards when i
mentioned it to her okay i said sammy
got upset
whatever you said it your wife told you
it was wrong it was not uh a good day
so
stop the [ __ ] let me let me
stop your baloney sammy i was man enough
to apologize to you and said it wasn't
meant intentionally to
to betray you your usual words or
anything else and i immediately took it
down so you could you could say whatever
you want as soon as i knew that i took
it down i said i apologize i didn't mean
it
i don't have to soften you up if it was
a mistake it was a mistake but there was
nothing said about you i didn't compare
you i went into great detail about the
witnesses that testified against my
father look at the video again
and i don't even know who those guys
were and i don't
care about those guys the innuendo is
that everybody should not get a [ __ ]
break because they cooperate they should
rise
[ __ ]
by the government so now you [ __ ]
crusader who wants to put everybody in
prison and then you say
they delay they come out and they
recommit
i'm talking about your vehicle what are
you doing what am i saying sammy can i
can i uh can i make one recommendation
apologize a hundred more times can i
make this whatever you want
if i can make it
here something's going on with this
phone yeah let me make one
recommendation sami
sami if we can if we can have you
uh uh mario's calling your phone if you
get the phone cause it's choppy with
your service michael's service is good
yours is a little choppy if you have the
phone next to you i'm gonna put it here
you will hear what michael has to say
and we will hear what you have to say i
don't have the phone patrick i do not
have the phone next to me i got it on
uh
airplane or whatever the [ __ ] it is to
shut it up and i'm not interested
in hearing what he has to say and i'm
not even interested in going on and
making sure
i'm starting to get tired of this
[ __ ] thing well then i'm tired of it
too
i'm tired of it too patrick okay it's
nonsense listen if you if
i have one ask for you guys i just have
one ask i have one ass go if you can
hear me you would consider listening to
me i just got one ask for you that's why
if we can't get a phone i don't know
who's out there sammy with you if you
can they can get a phone so you can hear
me better who's ever phoned out
here
can you have richie call mario have
richie call mario
have richie call mario if you don't mind
i just got one question for you what i
got i'm gonna ask i got one question
yeah because we can't hear you back no
we can't hear you back you're sounding
choppy and people can't hear you
if you're open to it i got one question
so rich
rich's
okay richie if you can call mario call
mario richie okay fantastic mario's
gonna bring the phone in i just got one
question for you guys i i uh and i wanna
make sure this is clear when i ask you
because for me uh listen we're not doing
this to create a war we're not trying to
create a fourth war here or anything
like that and you know the audience
they're not from the world this is
obviously not gonna go in that direction
but i do have one ask if you got richie
okay richie if you don't mind handing
the phone for to sammy that'd be great
okay if you got it if you want to put it
in
all right let's see if we can hear
better can we hear richie can you say
something
yeah
okay much better so if you want to now
mute sammy here
so we just hear sammy through phone
that'd be great
if you want to mute him on the zoom
there you go okay sammy can you hear me
yeah okay fantastic let me put it up
here
uh uh audience if you can hear just
comment below that you can hear it so
michael can you hear me as well
yeah i can hear you okay so i got a
question for you guys so i was sitting
down one time with stephanie hear him
okay because sammy can't hear okay so so
michael you know who stephen a smith is
sammy you may know who's here yeah
stephen a smith he's the espn guy and
and and
you know one day i'm sitting down with
him in new york and i don't know it was
connecticut or new york anyways we're in
new york city now talking to him
and i said stephen a a lot of these guys
are your friends like meaning in the
sports world and you come on and all of
a sudden you go after durant you go
after shaq you go after whoever but
these are your buddies these are your
friends what do you do with that i'll
never forget what he said he says you
know you know what i do it's a great
question you ask
i uh uh i whisper to them and i say hey
here's what i'm gonna say to you
tomorrow i just want you know i have to
do my job and i have to do this
uh uh you may want to skip tomorrow or
you know communicate with us tomorrow do
you think for for the two of you guys
that are the premier
youtube channels that are creating
content for this world do you think it
may be a good idea for the two of you
guys to communicate if at any time
contents being made that the other
person's name is being mentioned you
think that could solve something like
this moving forward i may be wrong i'm
just asking uh uh you know speculating
whether that would help because look
we'd like to see you guys being on
better mode than going in this place
we'd rather see you guys having a better
relationship michael maybe i can start
off with you do you think in the future
if you're ever going to do an episode if
you just say hey sammy i'm thinking
about doing an episode you're cool with
this or you know something like that or
would that not make a difference
patrick let me end it like this i don't
hear him okay i'm upset i don't know
what he's trying to doubt because i will
say this regardless of what he thinks or
what he's heard i did not do that
intentionally to betray him or hurt him
or make any innuendo in any way
whatsoever that's the truth i came out
of that sit down that we had actually
liking and respecting sammy and i happen
to really like and love his son gerard i
would never have done this to betray him
or hurt him in any way
never okay and the fact that he did it i
i fact that i did it i apologize it
wasn't meant to be done i'm very upset
that we've had these words because we
shouldn't have had them and you know
what if you would have called me up and
just said you know what what the hell
did you do maybe i wasn't thinking right
we had a kid die in our house you know
it's been a a real
bad thing in our family for the past
couple of weeks but maybe i would have
said you know what sam i know what the
hell i was thinking i'm sorry i
apologized anyway so the bottom line is
i don't know i don't know where his head
is at i'm a christian regardless what he
believes i am upset that i lost it here
a little bit but it's just my frame of
mind right now i apologize to you uh
patrick for you know for getting off a
little bit i normally don't do this you
know that i'm a pretty calm guy
but you know
look
my door is open
my door is open i'm not i'm not trying
to make enemies
whatever sammy wants to do and i mean
that we've said some bad words that
shouldn't have been said just now they
really shouldn't have been but
it is what it is and and i don't know
where we go from here but yeah i'm open
sammy
sammy can you hear me sammy can you hear
me yes i could hear that okay
uh
i heard him most of it
i think i think what what he's saying is
he's saying that he's open to i don't
know exactly what he's saying okay
i know exactly what he's saying
and uh i'm not really not a person who
carries grudges
i'm explosive in my personality and
things i do
i'm dedicated to what i do i'm dedicated
to friendship i'm dedicated to things
i've been betrayed a few times in my
life and i don't like it
betrayal just sets me on [ __ ] fire
but he said now
listen i feel the same way when we got
done with
mafia states of america
i actually felt better about him and
knowing him he knows it i spoke to
people who really don't know him and
they would badmouth him i told him
listen check them out
leave the guy alone it's
and he knows that all of that stuff
as far as his christianity he could have
it do whatever he wants with it i know a
lot of people who are
people believing things i believe in god
myself
i believe in religions have different
paths to god you don't have to be a
christian you could be anything an
indian uh
a jew you could be anything you want to
be to believe in god so i believe in god
as well
but i don't use him up front and i don't
use his name and i don't do all of that
stuff when i get mad or something that
says about christianity it's like you're
throwing these things in my face
and yeah i apologize for that what he
does right now is is an apology hey
i apologize things i just said
and i really don't want to hurt him in
any way i don't mean physically i mean
of course
there's nothing i want to do to hurt him
there's no reason for that for me
you know and he knows certain things
some of the things you said you know if
he knew that was married if his wife was
wise enough to know
she's not a gangster she's not a street
guy
the wife was wasn't up with it was one
day three days whatever this is going to
offend this way
now if i do videos my son is around my
son he talked good about my son my son
thinks the world
he's not here with me right now because
he had a feeling that this thing would
blow up and he didn't even want to see
it or hear it
because he likes movies
so how it's going to go in the future i
really don't know but i'm not mad i
don't have a bet i'm not mad at all in
any way they performed towards them
i don't know about going forward i don't
know if we would do business i have no
idea but you know
i don't really want to hurt them in any
way they perform and and you know sammy
i appreciate you saying that uh uh you
know having been around you guys for so
many hours and we've spent a lot of time
together both michael and yourself
interviews about conversations i've seen
you upset i've seen you this you know in
different levels
here's a couple of things that's very
random about these the the where you
guys were and where you are today
michael the way i judge is you know his
kids love him they're around him you
know his wife they're together we had
dinner at i don't know where we were at
casa de angelo wherever we were having
dinner or not even cassadine i think it
was shooters when you guys was your
first date 37 years ago i don't know
what uh the time you said to me michael
when you guys had dinner together you
know being married together for three
plus decades there's got to be value
there right and haven't stayed clean for
all these many years
there's respect for that and as sammy
for you and i see how gerard is how your
kids are with you
you know there's love there with the
family so there's good things being done
on both sides and both have decided to
move on i don't hear you again yeah uh
my my uh uh uh it it would be for maya
and my only suggestion i'm hearing you
so it's rich if you can figure right
away where he can hear me i want i want
sammy to hear this last part all right
okay michael sammy if you can't hear me
i'll go if you can hear me now looks
like service got better okay you know
the only thing i would say is this is my
biggest suggestion look i'm going to do
better if you guys want to go to war
like but that's not my outcome i'm not
doing this to make hey you know come on
let's pin them against each other this
is how we're going to make more money
that's not my outcome of doing this i
run businesses
and you know this was a story that the
world wanted to see the world wanted to
see to two of you guys sitting on having
a conversation together and the audience
is going to win because they're going to
hear both of you sitting down for 10
hours together for these episodes my
biggest suggestion is
if there's ever something being said or
content being created about opposing
side i i would process it with each
other both both of you guys are
heavyweights both of you guys are names
both of you guys are known in the
marketplace you're it's no longer you're
now public you know this is a pretty
private life you're accustomed to being
you're public now people follow your
story sam you run a very successful
podcast michael you're on a very
successful you know youtube channel that
you have with your shows and then the
restaurants and all the other things
that you guys do
my recommendation would be to have that
communication together anyways sammy
michael thank you guys uh for coming on
uh and uh uh agreeing to do this i do
know uh both of you guys at one point
were a little bit uncomfortable you were
not open for wanting to do this i'm glad
we were able to make this work today day
before thanksgiving uh appreciate you
guys for being on i'm gonna make a
couple announcements to the audience
right now while they're listening the
fact that mafia states of america is
going to be coming out december 3rd will
be the first day you can binge watch 10
episodes uh narrated by chas palm and
terry rudy giuliani's in there with a
couple of the episodes michael sammy
myself there's a lot of things that was
discussed if you've ever wanted to get
the insight from both of them sitting
face to face having a conversation to
get a high quality content
december 3rd it'll go out and for folks
that are asking about the cost at this
point of the game everybody knows what
the cost ended up being nearly half a
million dollars for a budget
of this that we put together uh you can
purchase the course not the course you
can purchase the uh entire episode
pre-order it today on mafia states of
america i think it's 39.99 to order the
whole 10 things
uh uh guys price point for us they were
saying pay-per-view 69.89 we agreed at
the number of 9.99 you can go there and
pre-order the whole thing and for some
of you guys that's saying i want to see
an episode we got i think two out of the
30 chapters are there for you to watch
for free you can go watch it for
yourself and meanwhile pre-order because
i'm sure there's going to be commentary
about this all over the world when this
is going to be released so once again go
to mafia states of america we're going
to put the link below above description
anywhere
for you to go see it so having said that
michael sammy thank you so much for your
time appreciate you guys i will follow
up with you guys thank you thank you all
right
thanks guys
uh mario final thoughts what are you
thinking right now
final thoughts for me is uh i'd
absolutely go and make sure i also
connect with not only
mafiastatesofamerica.com pre-order what
we have out there but i'd also go
connect with sam and michael just give
them their opinions on
you know how they felt about this
conversation any feedback go communicate
with michael communicate with sami and
make sure connect with them as the
audience as well fantastic folks we
tried very hard this has been a project
this has been in the works for uh three
years for three years now it's been
conversations for a long time we've been
working on making this happen we are
glad it finally happened i'm kind of
glad this ended on a good note to be
honest with you that was my biggest
thing the fact that it ended on a good
note because i i like when they
communicate the world learns more when
they're communicating together it's a
better community when that happens
because during the sit-down there was a
lot of heated moments let's not let's
not dispute that there was a lot of you
saw some of that right now so we saw
some of that right now but there's a
there's a lot more that of 10 hours of
content on the sit down a lot of depth a
lot of storylines a lot of the then and
now a lot of topics even current topics
even some some conversations that don't
really come up make a great boss today
correct you know when i showed the video
of when michael was on mike tyson and
you know there was a dispute and sammy
responded to what comments michael made
about sammy napoleon all this other
stuff they were open to any of the
discussions that we had uh uh whether it
was you know uh the wars you know
whether it was you know different
stories and characters that we brought
up it's pretty deep uh uh and for folks
who are interested in this topic i can't
wait for them to see that i think for
the for the years that you've been doing
mafia conversations mafia interviews sit
downs and all of these stories from
sitting down with the coladas and
natalies and all the michael and sammy
this whole i think it's important to
remember that you've never tried to
glamorize the life you've you're not
trying to bring more attention on look
at how cool it is you're not trying to
glamorize you're trying to bring
awareness tell the history and you're
trying to create a little bit of that um
storyline but also bring something
that's not done in movies yeah movies
are movies this is a real conversation
it's a great point you make look for me
you know everybody wants to learn the 10
keys to success i want to learn the 10
keys to mistakes you can make to ruin
your personal life
family finance dollars health that's
what i'm interested in because we all
know what we need to do the right things
what are the wrong things to do so we
don't do them sometimes we don't want to
go for the insurance yeah as somebody
who's going out there pre-ordering
watching this maybe experiencing the
first 20 minutes or you know what we're
going to watch today yeah um and then
online on the other maybe go back and
watch the michael interview the samurai
to freshen up on your content what do
you want people to take away from mafia
states of america that maybe is not on
the website not being promoted what do
you want the audience to get listen i
will tell you you know every family has
disputes every sports team business
there's typically a couple strong
personalities that don't have anything
to do with each other when you get
personalities like this that sit with
each other who learns you learn you say
you know what if they can get together
maybe me and my you know uh a brother
that haven't spoken for three years
maybe we need to have a conversation
maybe my friend and i that i've had
eight years falling out i like the fact
that we are more united having lived in
a time like this in america we're so
divided it's good to see people who are
agreeing to sit down because today
nobody wants to see the opposite side
everybody wants you just sit down with
people that they agree this is not an
easy thing to do neither one of them had
to agree to do something like this the
fact that they set them to do this
this wasn't easy it was pretty
uncomfortable at about 45 minutes it was
uncomfortable
but again i applaud them for having
agreed to do this folks i hope you uh
enjoyed this i can't wait for you to
binge watch this i want to hear all
about it when you do the commentary i'm
sure there's going to be a lot of
youtube videos right now being made
about today's exchange between between
michael and sammy and whoever sent you
here to see this you heard it from both
of them on how this ended so i want to
give a shout out to the entire crew that
was a part of the set whether you were
with us on the shoot or you've been
working on the project
there are so many people that i want to
give a lot of love and credit to behind
the scenes give some names
rose who's leading the editor here we
got rose we got eric david uh we have uh
paul we have nancy on the design we have
ted working on site we have a gerard big
organization everybody that's on the
team i don't want to forget names but so
many people kai sammy the entire
entertainment audience terry with his
contributions
rudy and we also have maria who helped
us facilitate that you know there's so
many people you'll see the credits but
again you're going to get a glimpse and
a flavor for everybody who was asking to
look at a lot of people were talking
[ __ ] about what are you doing what is it
coming out what is it coming out we get
it we want to deliver a great product we
do not have asked anything about team we
wanted to give a great product for the
last few weeks sorry what time have
people been going home be honest it'd be
three or five o'clock in the morning
david what time have people been going
home here the last few weeks four
o'clock
no you just stay all night all night
just to perfect this project guys yeah
just the color and took us one week
because we could have released this
earlier the coloring wasn't at the
levels that we wanted so many our guys
made us such a great anyways i can't
wait for crush to see it we're excited
about this uh we we are very uh excited
for you guys to go out and enjoy this
again december 3rd put it in your
calendar watch it with your family and
friends i suggest you guys going out
there sitting there with 5 10 15
different people use the hashtag on
twitter on instagram mafia states of
america there will be commentary as
people are talking about this go once
again to mafia state stock
of mafiastatesofamerica.com once again
mafiastateofamerica.com
pre-order 39.99 and if you want to watch
a free chapter or two it'll be on
mafiastatesamerica.com as well okay
thanks folks happy thanksgiving to all
of you enjoy the turkey tomorrow happy
thanksgiving
you